hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to vanish there has
been an update believe it or not this is
the release candidate for vanish and
they added things but to be honest don't
expect the outcomes gonna be any
different than it was before because I
remember being stuck in a perpetual hell
over and over and over again forever and
ever forever and ever and ever and ever
and ever and ever and ever and ever and
ever oh wow wait excuse me what's this
happened oh whoa I'm here against my
will
I can relate so much to that I would
rather be anywhere but playing this game
okay this makes so much more sense I
thought it was a maintenance worker
before oh okay all right then well oh
look at tutorial are you gonna tell me
how to beat the game I'm not gonna run I
know better than that
you save that for the emergencies oh oh
I just had a cold feeling pass through
my heart as if this is some message from
the gods of vanish that I will
constantly be turning around and not
making any progress
hey but I did I did see a screenshot
that had a sign on the wall pointing
towards certain water pump and
electrical rooms which probably means
that they're gonna be lies and then I
got a Saturday where I don't know and
you know I'm pretty sure they might
realize the developers of this game that
I have never been able to beat it and I
know I know that when I
I know for a fact that they probably
maybe a little bit might have input code
to recognize what I played by my
particular style that I will not be able
to meet because they're gonna make
everything be do see towards me and
they're gonna make it so that I never
ever ever ever ever ever make any
progress okay gotta come now I'd be nice
and calm about this
the new version hasn't been updated in
the body here haven't beaten it in about
a year but it could be fantastic I'm
just gonna give it the benefit of the
doubt I'm gonna I'm gonna praise it's
every elegant feature and never ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever take it
for granted because life is short you
need to cherish it when you can yeah I
don't know where I was going with that
I'm not a philosopher I'm not a
philosophize err I don't know anything
elegant about the secrets of life though
I may not claim that dire hi good to see
ya you're looking a little redder you
get some tan did you get a little Sun on
you don't get a lot of Sun down here do
ya tried to go to Venice Beach and get
sunburned you came back and all your
mole friends made funny if you could
just point me towards where I'm supposed
to go
I'll greatly appreciate that obviously
I've said in the past game great gravely
made well made super cool concept very
scary in the beginning when I first Oh
guys I'll just go down here nuts into
the walls a floor or into the tunnel of
death yay though I walk through the
tunnel of death I would hope that you
don't be mean to me
because my heart couldn't take it it'll
break into a million pieces if you beat
mean to me you guys wouldn't be meet you
hello why are you looking brother Chiba
did I oh is that a message from why not
just fooling myself that's real isn't it
what happens if I go down there so badly
oh oh well that's new I found the
generator how could it be so happy and
then it's gonna be ripped away from me
but oh my god I found it oh wow
none of these glow sticks actually do
anything I cut half of one was any me
nope still just as ineffective as ever
but maybe they're better than nothing
you'd think that some sort of light
would be able to scare these mole people
away not that any of these actually
shoot ultraviolet radiation which is
probably what they're not [ __ ] do that
right when I'm turning around
yeah I was worried for a second there
yeah yeah I know good jingle jangle I'm
trapped cuz I don't know who threw me in
there that seems like something that the
SCP people would do and see people I
said pee pee hahaha but either way that
seems like something the SCP people
would do and this stop laughing and this
seems like you know the kind of
dastardly dungeon that is actually
manifested by a malevolent force of some
sort there's only the second note that I
found hello there's something definitely
following me I swear if that's you Phil
I'm going to kill you oh maybe I am Phil
and Hank is actually one of those grete
maybe we're all mole people
nice but you look good you've been doing
them squat thrusts like a talk yeah I
got nothing to say about that okay so
this games get a little more interesting
notice how the lighting edition these
are new sound all over the blades I
don't much care for them
why am i breathing don't be I mean of
course I should be breathing but why did
I breathe just then in there why did I
give a sigh of relief come on I just
lost wheeze them buns OOP okay so I got
the exit here there's no way in hell
it'll ever be here by the time I get
back you still there
no why are you undulating why are you
moving wibbly-wobbly
don't be wibbly-wobbly I don't like that
I don't like that oh right don't you
will join me whittle away whittle away
whiffle the way
okay
shut up busy I'm supposed to do is he's
never gonna go away try one more time oh
look here I go what's more under the
breech maybe I shouldn't even bother
maybe I shouldn't even try because
they're still there still no way I'm
gonna be able to beat this there's no
way I can't beat this there is
impossible for me anyone else can you
guys can and you guys can prove it by
downloading the game and playing it for
yourself wings in the description I bet
if you play it you'll beat it unlike the
third try maybe even the first try you
won't even have a problem with it but me
me me em do have problem
mium do bad
anyway whatever whatever and you know
it's not just what you guys have seen
that I've tried it's not just that what
has happened is that I have actually
played this many more times than you
guys have seen on my own recording other
things that I then threw away
I have been playing this game a lot and
every time every time every time does it
let me win it just doesn't it can't it's
impossible it won't it refuses it can't
it won't [ __ ] it don't it grant that's
not even a word and it does that because
it's it specifically it's me
I think it's just an actual big
conspiracy where there's actually no one
that has beaten this game and the
developers have talked to everyone else
that's new that is new that's new at the
in private and given them builds that
are feasible while I am here squandering
my life away and what is to be a
destitute endeavor where death and
lackadaisical Ness awaits me in the
darkness so that's what I have to say
about the weather is good how about that
smart scam in Brazilian there's a lot of
points being done a lot of goalie units
man did you see those impacts whoa
those were some bio weather - whoo it's
been a day
real atmospheric in a lot of ways great
could I just don't like to keep myself
and get it over with or maybe I grab one
of those and electrocute the monster
that would seem like a better solution
than what I'm doing if I was in here I'm
gonna dropkick him in the balls long ago
damn it did you
stay here hey don't use naughty I said
god damn it I said no don't walk away
from me yeah seriously really oh no
changed Oh chase anymore
oh good is there well I didn't work long
is the dick with you stands objective is
make if you lost make you feel like
you're lone trapped unable to escape and
goddamn that doesn't make it
its exact purpose and thing that is
doing well I'm on there now baby after a
while this place won't be so bad
I can't understand you're just mumbling
have you done none see any more use your
lips
I didn't want to look over there one
more try
I don't care what you guys say I don't
care I don't care you guys but telling
me that there's a pattern you need to go
left right left left left right left
right left
I've gone right left right left right
left left off right I've gone specific
pattern say you guys say that I've been
telling that you've told me that I've
done I've tried everything
I've tried an on camera and off camera
I've done it all just to see if it was
possible I've been wandering around for
about five inclination of a thing I've
found no things that's cool that
happened I think I took the wrong turn I
don't know that all these days did you
just gasp in me what are you looking at
a note are you Phil and my demise did
you bag me a despise image for research
no lock don't forgetting your cat
wriggle we can't wait to see it for a
third time before I find anything else
really didn't like anybody looking at
him I thought they were blind oh look
another note I'm gonna get the whole
collection oh my have fun in hell Oh
Jesus I shouldn't have gone into this
hole oh god did he come into the hole
after me no no no behind me anything
here's a bribe a house I'm in the back
my ears Oh Oh God have a choice about I
made the wrong one come by me
whoa where am i okay I don't know what
this means
oh where we going where we going where
we going where we going where we going
where we going where we go go go
I don't know where anything is I don't
know where I'm going another entrance
why can't I cycle through the notes that
I got I want to see that other one the
one with the map that was totally
useless to me Oh God is one of you
actually want to try it's gonna make me
die don't ever look back no follow the
pipes don't run don't run the whispers
lie I ran I think I've done bad Oh does
not matter where I go I'm gonna get lost
in the snow but it's not so it's
nightmares I'm gonna get lost in
nightmares I'm gonna go eat babies I'm
gonna eat boil babies while babies
bottle babies I'm gonna kill all the
animals go all the animals kill them
just kill them dead shot
that that's a pipe but that led me right
to where I need to go great thing I got
to these glow sticks oh oh no oh no is
that a cave-in oh no no no no no no no
no no no what happened what happened
what up are you okay is everybody okay
in here is anybody hurt is anybody hurt
well things took a turn for the okay oh
okay
hatred into this one did it work did it
work did it work aren't you gone Roberto
did you go away forever and die did you
get lost in the pitch of hell did you
decide to go and never bother me again
oh no
okay suddenly I'm not liking this yes I
hit this shift button oh there's bees
damn bees everywhere okay everything is
getting a lot more intense all of a
sudden I don't want you okay no no don't
let the darkness closed in
goodbye darkness my old enemy I hope I
never see you again oh no no no no claim
II don't claim II don't claim me into
the dark I can actually take it all I
need to turn around don't leave me
claim me no I don't want to walk into
the darkest I want to walk into the
light which way do I go straight back
tunnel open see that [ __ ] myself I have
taken way too long
goodbye okey-dokey
oh no the darkest whoop it up open it up
open up darkness get closer
in twitchy I'm getting twitchy guys I'm
getting no Oh what I'm not dead I'm
gonna do it
this listen I'm not tired
I've been playing this round for a long
time I hear again how do I get back bang
her I've seen the entrance like five
times I've seen everything like ten
bajillion times I just need to not boost
do not L do show me don't trap me in a
corner don't cave me in right no I've
read these before I've done this before
it's like every sect but I'm still
winning I can win this I know I can
Watson oh it's to collect listen
didn't I just collect that same note
don't look at notes
back back I'm not gonna break any rules
I'm not gonna do anything out of the
ordinary
oh I got the keys oh it says I'll get
these that's so hard warming is ooh
beautiful
I'm going in the tone screw it I'm now
you're gonna give them in the chance to
scorn me maybe gonna give them the
chance not even gonna try to do anything
if I could just is that the somber sound
music of goodness happiness
everyone please start chanting in the
comments mark you can do this don't suck
everybody chant this mark you can do
this dose up mark you can do this so
suck mark you're gonna do this nose up
mark you do this up high you're not
you're not doing it why aren't you I'm
gonna lose because you didn't do it you
didn't do it it's too late to go back
now
you can't go back a type board too late
those of you who didn't do it my very
last one Oh God better look if I run
straight I don't have to go back in the
tunnel it'll change let's eat
oh god stop jerk of a camera around run
run run run run keep running keep
running no time to waste
why the tunnel won't even be there now
Ron Ron Ron you [ __ ]
Ronnie Odo's thank you thank you for
running holes that did I just step on a
rat
do not kill me you gonna be strong man
oh my god
what is that what huh what no what no I
used but the habit what was that what
was there a gate it looks like a gate
that I could have a life to get out did
they like perchance take up the spawn of
the gate that could have been in it like
it was a 50/50 ugly or it could be an
open gate her the way I do this is right
we do have a go today
feels so good I feel so warm inside my
heart I feel so good oh it feels so good
you guys don't even understand how much
this beats to be oh this games been
played me for a year do you know how
many emails and Twitter comments and all
that was like so thank you all so much
for watching thank you
I'm gonna go hug every stranger I meet
ever in the world ah I feel so good okay
anyway thank you all so much for
watching
oh if you ought to see the tragedy that
befell me before this there's a whole
playlist of my failure and the vast up
until this point but either way thank
you all so much for believing in me and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
you